when I had my accident I found out at
that moment nothing in life is promised
except death when someone comes up and
says something like I am a god everybody
says who does he think he is I just told
you who I thought I was Oh God
I just told you that's who I think I am
to this date they do not understand who
I am they didn't they will not
understand till after I'm gone he's an
American rapper songwriter record
producer a fashion designer and
entrepreneur he's among the most
acclaimed musicians of the 21st century
and is one of the best-selling artists
of all time
he's also been included in a number of
the Forbes annual list
he's Kanye West and here's my take on
his top ten rules for success vol 2 and
as always guys if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below put
quotes around it as well so other people
can be inspired also when you write it
down you're much more likely to lock it
in for yourself as well
enjoy
then I just had the hunger like my
mother never raised me to ask for a
handout like a lot of people that got
into the game they walking around
somebody else is chained on or driving
somebody else's car and didn't even pay
for the shoes that they got on they feet
my mother had a decent job you know I'm
saying but she gave me a little ounce
fifteen twenty dollars a week and I had
to go out and get my own job at age 15
not affect at 14 I was cutting here in
the barber shop so it was instilled in
me to go out and just get it and that
that maybe me be a leader around a lot
of black men like even my father had I
had two fathers in my life I had my real
father that was in contact with my
stepfather that stayed there with my
mother and everybody was instilling that
responsibility in me that nothing in
life is given to you a lot of times I
feel like a lot of people just rapping
because it's free you know saying what
you got to do especially now with Jay
writing is Robin here if you ain't got
to pay for paper number one everybody
just feel like this one to just don't
say come out be a rap out of the blue at
least with a production you have to go
up and figure out a way to get your
equipment up and go buy records and do
different things so I'm talking about
the work ethic is so serious and up here
at baseline up to the rock people work
the work that gets crazy that's why I
feel like we we killing a game right now
it's why we cutting edge that's why we
don't flex every week just question
label that's why all you hear
practically into rock when I have my
accident I found out at that moment
nothing in life is promised to stuff
death
if you had the opportunity to play this
game of life you need to appreciate
every moment a lot of people don't
appreciate that moment until it's passed
[Music]
[Applause]
and then you got to tell those Al Bundy
stories you remember when I but um right
now it's my time and my moment thanks to
the fans thanks to the accident thanks
to God thanks to rockefeller Jay Z's
name - gee my mother Rhymefest everyone
that's helped me and I planned
I plan to celebrate I plan to celebrate
and scream and pop champagne every
chance I get cuz I'm not the Bradley
I know I know every I know everybody
asked me the question they wanted to
know what kind I knew he's going all out
and he's gonna do something crazy
everybody wants to know what I would do
if I didn't win I guess we'll never know
you don't realize I am so frustrated
like I am so frustrated like I am so
I've got so much I want to give I've got
ideas on color palettes I've got ideas
on silhouettes and I've got a million
people telling me why I can't do it you
know that I'm not a real designer I'm
not this I'm not a real rapper either
I'm not a real musician either like I
don't know how to play the piano like
I'm an artist I went to art college I
went to art college and was looked at
like I'm soft because I like wore like
Italian clothes you know saying when I'm
rapping in front of camera and my pants
is tight trying to spit a verse of care
you know so that's the saying when I'm
sitting there you know like sitting
there out of fashion show like I'm there
because I appreciate Phoebe Philo I
appreciate Rice Evans I appreciate
Riccardo Tisci and I look at them as my
peers as creative people who dedicate
their entire life to making something
better for the world is I mean let me
explain what anybody that knows are
artists and you know someone that's
giving that if you know artists there's
only one thing you can say give or ask
them when you see them there are two
words thank you there's no why don't you
do this y'all okay
what's up know we dedicate our entire
life to making our current time and
civilization better to adding something
to the culture and there is only two
words that you can say thank you you
acquainted yourself to all these
different people in DaVinci Walt
Disney's if Jose Michelangelo and he
lost how would you define a genius in
that context but would say why do you
feel the need to call yourself that
because otherwise I'm called celebrity
I'm called [ __ ] I'm called rapper and
when they use the word celebrity [ __ ]
or rapper it's not in a positive way
and all these things all those words can
be used in an extremely positive way
what's up my [ __ ] you know but that's
not the way it's used so I have to
define who I am you know all of my
aspirations are things that currently
only 60 year old white people do so I
have to redefine and let people know
exactly who I have and it's not letting
them know by you know wearing the suit
but later the Novaya wearing a Rolex or
let them know by you know bragging about
how much money a sponsorship made on top
of a rap is letting them know by saying
let's start with this I'm a creative
genius and it's proven you know will
continue to prove it you know six albums
original albums of your own a throne
record various records with good music
to talk about man but seriously users
Bravo dude I mean that is one of the
most creative records of you know of any
genre I've had in a very very long time
and you know in terms of your output the
most exciting sounding record I think
man oh thank you very much you know yeah
so you know I was able to start just
making exactly what was in my mind again
I'm not having to speak with the
textures of the time because you know
cool summer is definitely Kanye West and
it's something kind of weird and off
about mercy like when it has the high
pitch and that type of sound it sounds
like art still a little bit even though
it obviously was a radio smash but it
still when I you know get into the idea
like the trap drums and things like that
are certain you know songs that are
blatant you know radio hits it's like
I'm speaking with today's texture and
that's you know and you look if you look
at it 200 years from that it's not going
to stand out in the way that you know
808 or Jesus stands out and completely
can push or redefine or make people say
you know hey I completely hate that or I
completely love that but let me just
think
friendly because everybody is like bound
to these you know no pun intended
they're bound to 16 bars and eight bars
and you know the normal or radio or the
radio thing I was talking to Frank Ocean
about this and said like you know my mom
got arrested for the sit-ins and now
we're more like to sit out like sit off
of radio yeah and say hey radio come to
us yeah you know we need to find
something new because it's being you
know controlled in a way and
manufactured in a way that it you know a
really awesome you know artists you know
can make amazing music and in that break
as far past it's like something that's
very like formulaic so it almost feels
like a duty to you in a weird way having
the people here having people's
attention and for great music to be able
to say well if I'm not challenging them
I'm not challenging myself not
challenging radio what am i doing yeah
well I'm not I'm not trying to
regurgitate myself I show I showed
people that I understand how to make
perfect you know dark fantasy could be
considered to be perfect you know I'd
say I know how to make perfect but
that's not what I'm here to do I'm here
to crack and crack the pavement and make
new grounds you know sonically and in
society culturally some people say
everyone with was born an artist and
society their parents they beat it out
of them oh you know this time there was
there was someone after I said I was
going to run for president that showed
me like a videotape of somebody making
me making fun of me about that concept
and I was thinking like wow if this
person was doing this from my age of
three I would have never been me and you
know people say geniuses are kids with
good parents so
how do you nurture the things that
people would call weird and just
something that could be considered to be
something that would be exceptional
thank you so many movies are based on
this antihero
that's up against all odds doing the
exceptional I was always rapping and it
just so happened that really really
phenomenal rappers got the rap on my
beats before I got a chance to so that
pushed me into the classification of a
producer but I'm a rapper from the heart
like I got something to say you don't
say and people like you what you kind of
rap about you never so crack out your
house and put a gat to a mouth and put
your fist to your spouse so how you
going to move the crowd I bet a thousand
that you get booed out you know they're
like now the rap game has changed I want
to go from trial called questions to
addicts to Swizz Beatz to rockefeller to
the bad boy and so many different sounds
and it's you know it's like almost
playing like double just like what are
you getting the Gabe you lady trying to
like you know how does my style fit into
what I'm doing right now so I'm lucky
that I had the opportunity to have a
plateau to stand on now that my style of
beats is the most popular style on the
radio right now now I turn on here beat
that I could have sworn I did them by
just did get no checks was it that's
what's with equal vertical does what I
do to do the good on sexual so now that
my staff is now it's like the world can
accept me it's a lot of people it's like
you just got to get in where you fit in
you never know how you get in you might
be somebody's guy and you end up being
better than that person is signing over
that person you might be a intern or
it's like the question is how do you get
into the industry how do you get into
the shoes on there right now I'm just
happy to be here but as the artist like
I'm not going to waste this opportunity
I'm going to take this to the next level
like I'm in when Pop first got idea I
said yo man Snoop smoke is killing the
game I'm offering to take dev Road to
the next level I'm like what too far
from to do better than Snoop come on out
but now look
we got this new thing called classism
it's racism cousin this is what we do to
hold people back this is what we do and
we got this other thing that's also been
working for a long time but you don't
have to be races anymore it's called
self hate it works on itself it's like
real estate of racism where just like
that when someone comes up and says
something like I am a god
everybody says who does he think is I
just told you who I thought I was Oh God
I just told you that's who I think I am
would have been better if I had a son
and said I am a [ __ ] or if I had a son
- I'm a gangster or a badass honest I am
a pimp all those colors and patinas fit
better on a person like me right but to
say you are God especially when you got
shipped over to the country that you're
in and your last name is the slave
owners how could you say that how could
you have that mentality I mean I know in
the past you've talked about like you
know building hotels
doing things that are beyond people's
normal frame of reference yeah they know
you as Kanye West and artists they know
that you're moving into fashion but
these things I guess in a way are hard
for people to comprehend because they
don't have that level of Drive do you
know what I mean has it always been like
this for you have you always felt like
you can set your mind to anything and
you will achieve it ultimately I always
felt like I could do anything that's the
main thing people are controlled by dogs
their perception of themselves they're
slowed down by their perception of
themselves if you're taught you can't do
anything you won't do anything I was
taught I could do everything for and I'm
Calle West at age 36 so just watch the
next 10 years originally I went to art
school I had scholarships at a point in
high school a white dog is going to be
an artist what did you do some of these
just pieces right here dad calm 94 95
most of these related ok what's this you
got a blue ribbon on this one that's
what I want
Dracula - yeah
all over this I was really in this anime
and Japanese art this one is kind of
eerie it was a good exercise that the
teacher gave us and it's not very good
but since it was the dude looking like
he was dead I just put my name on them
put 1977 to 1995 which is a year which I
actually drew it and so I should have
killed me first how bad was actually was
but but this is almost like a
premonition of a sort of because you
know you were like this doctor attending
a car accident if you were in the bed
like this that you thought was a
deathbed right so I would never draw
myself dead ever again
you ever find time to do this anymore
seldomly now drawing on just use as a
language like I wanted to look like this
I love is raw bodies of love uses more
see my things
think about the drawings is I couldn't
turn them up loud enough I wanted to do
something where people have it on all
the time and basically now what my music
is is a soundtrack to millions of
people's lives you couldn't get that
feeling from article I couldn't get it
39 year old Caillou let's talking to you
right now play to [ __ ] that continued I
built things that mean things to people
I make the Christmas present to this
date they do not understand who I am
they didn't they will not understand
till after I'm gone
so you asked me hood I look up to him
like I'm inspired by Walt Disney I'm
inspired by Howard Hughes I'm inspired
by Henry Ford I'm inspired by Steve Jobs
for me money is not my definition of
success inspiring people is a definition
of success doing things to the maximum I
want to change the definition of status
quo and that's what I want I want I want
my shoes I want as many people to be
able to have them as possible because in
a hundred years from now everyone in
this room will be dead and what did you
do while you're here
you guys so much for watching I'd love
to know what did you think of this video
and what do you think in general about
the volume 2 series leave it down
comments below super curious to find out
also I'd love to know what did you learn
from Kanye in this video what lessons
stuck out the most for you that you're
going to immediately apply to your life
or to bits or somehow please leave it in
the comments below and I'll join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Michael thank you so
much Michael for picking up a copy of my
book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
I remember back in grammar school we
used to have rap groups and I had to
write the raps for all the rap group
um I remember this one time um we're
trying to do a talent show this is where
I learned pick your audience yours is
like you got to figure out who you were
actually rapid too because I have my
music teacher it was my favorite teacher
in the world miss Morgan and you know
saying she was like it's kind of like
the lane Bryant size or whatever you're
there and we got up there and we think
we're going to perform fat girls are
back for the talents of so of course we
did make it at that point I was like um
you know then figure out who you rap
into it's like do I worry about you know
being in the public eye and raising kids
yeah any situation your hand you're
going to worry about raising kids but
it's you know the champagne problems too
these people can't feed their kids
that's something more to worry about so
I'm not going to sit here and complain
about is the so-called issues I have
these aren't real issues there's people
at war there's people trying to make it
to London right now there's Pete you
know I mean it's like it's really
serious you guys talk to me about like
some celeb you know that that's not real
you know I mean it's the time it's a
madam upset of this bed all they got
that wrong about me you know I'm alive
I'm breathing I did a show we sell it we
do it a second collection I had no
problems